ich habe vor fünf jahren unglaublich
gerne werte auf youtube geguckt hatte
früher eine serie namens world und euro
und in der hand der quasi drei
verschiedene charaktere selbst gespielt
die miteinander eine konversation
geführt haben das hat mir mein lieblings
format von ihm leider hat er das jetzt
seit mehreren jahren nicht mehr
hochgeladen
da eher inaktiv jetzt mittlerweile auf
youtube ist ich möchte mich mit dem
heutigen video auf jeden fall mal so ein
bisschen daran orientieren an dieser
herbert und ursache und ihr seht schon
titel eingeblendet ich zeige euch heute
meine schwester beziehungsweise auch
meinen bruder deswegen hey film habe wie
ich meine schwester und mein bruder eure
kommentare kommentieren
everything is made in china except babys
der maid wird gina ich ja da war ich mit
dem unterwegs erfahren was gästen so
richtig geilen laden ja richtig hammer
der doch gezahlt so ist war ich tue was
luca ist dumm also jetzt mal ganz
neutral betrachtet würde ich da gern mal
anmerken das ist natürlich sehr sehr
gerne mal einen iq-test hier mit luca
durch ihren film alter das ist nur so
ein insider meiner community wir müssen
als keinen iq test oder irgendwie sowas
machen das alles cool ich schreibe das
hat voll auf meine kommentare und sohn
iq-test bräuchten wir allerhöchstens mal
verluste
kg besteht zu 100 prozent recht luca die
nicht mehr wirklich mal verluste
ich hoffe es wird immer von mir
warum braucht man mathe in der schule
mathe braucht man nicht
ich kann auch rechnen ja gut los dann
beantworten doch einfach mal folgende
fragestellung und zwar wie viele in
diesem raum hier haben lange haare wenn
es 66 hier in kurze haare haben
sie sind doch gar nicht zu viele
was ist die lieblings regel eines afg
sympathisanten rechts vor links
okay der job das ist wirklich ein
durchaus gelungener wird es besonders
aufgrund der aktuellen geschehnisse
nicht wahllos sie verstehe ich nicht
welcher shop ist der beste der welt
genau luca - shop.de liebe jack erstmal
danke für diesen tollen kommentare da
ist auf jeden fall alles richtig
geschwitzt shop.de verbindlich schon von
den ganzen welt nahmen sie dann würde
ich doch sagen rufen wir einfach mal die
website news.de im webbrowser auf
tja lucy sowie das hier aussieht ist die
website leider nicht verfügbar freunde
gar keine ahnung ich nicht alles richtig
update ist die gruppe noch gar nicht
sagen
[Musik]
schumacher soll erst mal zu zweit weiter
wenn man sich vornimmt den ganzen tag
nicht zu erreichen und das dann auch
geschafft hat man ja doch was erreicht
oder da du in deiner aussage hier ganz
klar gebrauch des gesetzes der doppelten
negation macht sind zeigt mir dass sie
wirklich dass du einer der wenigen
menschen bis bei denen man die frage zu
beantworten ja darauf wollte ich auch
hinaus haben 10 10 habe ich geburtstag
luca darf ich mal ganz kurz daran
erinnern dass am 10 10
wie du selbst gesagt hast oder eventuell
eine woche später hat eine eigene pizza
rauskommt in den handel bestimmen danke
nochmal an der dann cool
meine oma ist in der sauna eingeschlafen
hildegard
[Musik]
schon mal was von schule gehört aufgrund
der tatsache dass so zeger jedes kind in
die schule geht würde ich da hingehen
tatsächlich ein bisschen schule vater
und ich habe für viel geworden
[Musik]
na was denn am ende ja ich ja eher luca
deutschen fleisch kaufen gehen ja wollen
wir das hier vielleicht noch 400.000
leute den kommentaren schreiben ja ich
wurde halt operiert haben kann wenn man
halt operiert wird natürlich bei der
nach der haltung
warum guckt ihr mich so an leute ihr
habt da auch alle pflaster kleben hier
bist du ich gucke das video um 19 uhr 37
alter ohne spaß was gerade übels der
zufall also es ist gerade 1944 jetzt
nicht ganz 1937 aber als halb voll
luca also tut mir leid dass ich jetzt
hier ganz kurz eben unterbrechen muss
aber bei mir ist es schon 20 uhr 1 auf
dem handy ludger das liegt daran weil
ich uns alle nacheinander aufgenommen
habe und dementsprechend halt auch zu
unterschiedlichen zeiten
das macht halt einfach dein maul
losgemacht eine kag website jetzt
endlich mal auf was hat das jetzt
eigentlich mit deiner website so richtig
ergeben
wenn ich fragen darf ein portfolio mit
sich machen alltag von ram und dann
kannst du mal versuchen mit einem
regenschirm als die tür auf einem
nashorn über die wolken zu galoppieren
wie ich schätze da wär ich möchte jetzt
gar nicht unterbrechen lucy aber ich
glaube dieser kommentar war an luca
gerichte der den ganzen fragen und so
weiter auch ausgesucht und ihm gehört
auch dieser kanal hier ja auch stimmt
glaube ich auch also um auf die fragen
bzw
die challenge zurückzukommen
nein kann ich leider nicht machen weil
ich habe erstens keiner vor mir und ich
bin der wind in dieser päckchen kaffee
holen damit die ganze zeit wird der
zusammenhang hier scheinbar ruhig ja ich
versuche hier ein video aufzunehmen
würdest du kennst du ja ruhig hier
bekannt wer das wollen sich die strabag
links bot sich gleich am ende bist du
bescheuert oder beleidigst mich denn
jetzt hier alters kann man schon gar
nicht war seine versuche ganz normalen
wieder aufzunehmen mit ludger und dir
und du kommst die andere das auch einmal
in stress mit einem freund alter was
soll das denn jemand in den schicken
bevor das kann sich jetzt auf eskalieren
würde ich mich an der stelle ja schon
mal verabschieden ich meine damen und
herren ludger ist raus ja und er muss
sich streiten sich jetzt noch ein
bisschen das war's jetzt jedoch von
video meine damen und herren ich hoffe
es hat euch vielleicht gegen die
gefallen werde ich jetzt hier mit lucy
ludger und mit mir selbst mit luca ein
bisschen untereinander kommuniziert habe
so ein paar kommentare von euch
beantwortet habe auf so ein paar
kommentare reagiert habe auf dumme
sachen auf linz reagiert habe wenn ihr
wollt dass sich das eventuell nochmal
hochladen das war es natürlich ein
heidener aufwand gegen die zwei stunden
lang jede position habe zu drehen das
drehbuch allein erstmal zu schreiben
alles raus zu suchen und jetzt noch
zusammen zu schneiden wenn ich das
allerdings gefallen hat und jetzt bock
daran dass ich so was eventuell mal
wöchentlich hochladen anlass gerne mal
ein like da und ja das was ihr vom video
das war's jetzt hier vom video hier
können jetzt hier mal den kanal
abonnieren oder hier
meinen schenken jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent zeit könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann bekommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]